vemos que sucede con este vídeo vamos a
razonar un poco esta situación veamos
que si llamamos a a este a esta
expresión ve a esta y sea esta podríamos
realizar una propiedad distributiva
cuestión que nos quedaría x x x cuadrado
más xy más y cuadrado menos y por x
cuadrado más xy más y cuadrado y si
seguimos desarrollando todas estas
distributivas tenemos x al cubo más x
cuadrado y más x cuadrado
- x cuadrado y menos x cuadrado menos
y esto si después seguimos viendo esta
cuestión tenemos que este este valor
este término se puede anular con este y
este se puede anular con este por lo que
esto nos queda igual a x al cubo menos y
al cubo es decir nosotros podemos
afirmar ya que realizamos toda esta
propiedad distributivo usando pasos
lógicos que esta expresión es igual a
equis cubo menos y kurt ahora nos
preguntamos si lo que acabamos de hacer
es un razonamiento
razonamiento inductivo
es esto un razonamiento inductivo lo que
acabamos de hacer lo que acabamos de
comprobar lo que acabamos de demostrar
bueno la respuesta es claramente no
lo que acabamos de hacer se trata de un
razonamiento deductivo en donde usamos
verdades absolutas y pasos lógicos para
llegar de una expresión de esta
expresión nos a volver acá
para llegar de esta expresión que está
en violeta a la expresión que está en
rojo esta expresión llegamos a esta otra
expresión utilizando pasos lógicos y eso
es justamente lo que se trata o lo que
hace un razonamiento
razonamiento
deductivo
deductivo es decir partir de una verdad
absoluta de un hecho utilizando todas
las verdades todos los hechos todas las
cuestiones lógicas para llegar a otro
hecho y otra verdad es decir esto no es
una conjetura esta expresión esto que
nosotros hicimos no fue una conjetura
sino que fue una demostración por lo
tanto como pudimos comprobar y demostrar
esta propiedad decimos que estamos
haciendo un razonamiento vamos a hacer
así un razonamiento deductivo